[Musik]
wurden von soldaten begleitet denn es
herrschte bürgerkrieg
dann beging in ein ländliches
kambodschanisches dorf und das war
völlig still dass wir plötzlich das
weinen einer frau r als wir die hütte
erreichten sahen wir eine mutter die
sich die seele aus dem leib weinte weil
ihr sohn gerade an malaria gestorben war
das hat mich sehr getroffen auch als ich
zurückkam denn ich hatte noch nie zuvor
ein kind sterben sehen
[Musik]
ich denke immer an diese mutter gesicht
die augen aus dem kopf eine junge
gestorben als ich dann in singapur ankam
fand ich heraus dass ich eine art von
malaria hatte die das gehirn angreift
und nicht behandelt werden konnte der
arzt rief meine familie an weil er sich
nicht sicher war ob ich die nacht
überleben würde
[Musik]
am nächsten tag wachte ich auf und
fühlte mich als hätte ich kambodscha in
meinem blut
die tragödie der mutter und ihres kindes
noch vor augen sagte ich zum simonetta
dass wir denen helfen soll hätten
betroffen sind und leiden um zu
versuchen etwas zu tun
[Musik]
und
es ist nur noch ein monat bis zur
eröffnung der kochakademie für tami ist
damit ein traum in erfüllung gegangen 27
jahre nach seiner berufung
die schule ist das ergebnis von sechs
jahren harter arbeit einer öffentlich
privaten partnerschaft mit starkem
schweizer einfluss wir hoffen dass sie
in kambodscha einen langen weg gehen
wird
[Musik]
wallis und thurgau es ist ein bisschen
deutschland ein bisschen frankreich und
ein bisschen italien uns geht es gut
solange wir nicht über politik reden
kein röstigraben
[Musik]
heute machen wir spaghetti die
nudelmaschine auszuprobieren also machen
wir sizilianische pasta mit garnelen und
baby tintenfisch in einer tomaten
petersilien sauce als vorspeise
markus und jean-marc machen
schweinebauch
[Musik]
alles beginnt wenn man ein kind ist
als ich zehn jahre alt war haben ich und
mein nachbar angefangen selbst zu kochen
ich habe immer für viele menschen in
asien gekocht ohne die ich koche um geld
zu sammeln
dann habe ich mich in einigen
restaurants & catering unternehmen
engagiert
meine leidenschaft
[Musik]
für unsere familie meine frau und meine
kinder ist es ein enorm wichtiges
projekt romy hat sich damit beschäftigt
als sie ihre machbarkeitsstudie mit der
schule erstellte
projektvorschlag sie hat in diesem
sektor und auf diesem gebiet studieren
es ist also etwas ganz besonderes wir
denken oft dass wir ihr andenken ehren
mit dieser schule weitermachen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nomis geschichte eine tragische
geschichte
eine mutter oder ein vater wie ihren
eigenen sohn oder ihre eigene tochter
begraben müssen
[Musik]
mir ist klar geworden dass sich jahre
damit verbracht habe leuten trost zu
spenden die jemanden verloren haben
wie einen vater dessen tochter in der
nähe unseres projekts gefunden wurde sie
war mehrfach vergewaltigt worden wir
waren
arm abgetrennt worden
als sich die geschichte hörte ging ich
zu dem vater und er umarmte mich begann
zu weinen
er sagte ich habe einen traum müssen sie
ich habe vier töchter mein traum ist ist
die jüngste zur schule zu schicken und
jetzt habe ich eine tochter verloren
und mein traum ist gestorben
ich weinte und sagte ich werde nicht nur
eine sondern zwei schulen bauen in
erinnerung an seine tochter
[Musik]
nachdem wir viele menschen getroffen
haben die in einer ähnlichen situation
sind haben wir nun
in dieser geschichte in der es an uns
liegt nach vorne zu schauen
[Musik]
nach einer ermutigung zu suchen
wenn wir die erinnerung an sie wach
halten
die wunschschule millimeter
[Musik]
wir kämpfen einen hoffnungslosen kampf
denn wir glauben an die auferstehung
wir glauben dass naomi im himmel ist und
wie sie wieder sehen werden und dann ist
da noch die bitterkalt darüber nicht
die schule zu sehen
und
wie sie zum altar getragen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es geschah als unsere tochter nomi stab
und ich mich entscheiden musste was sich
als nächstes tun will womit will ich
meine zeit verbringen was ist mir
wichtig mir wurde klar was das
wichtigste für mich ist hier unter
menschen zu sein
[Musik]
das ist eine sonderklasse diese kinder
haben eine behinderung und wir schaffen
es fünf bis sieben von ihnen in einer
klasse zu haben eben klassenzimmer
nebenan sind die kinder aggressiver so
dass der lehrer nur vier bis fünf
schüler aufnehmen kann
manchmal sind die schüler nicht in der
lage zu sprechen sie benutzten farben
oder zeichnung zu kommunizieren wenn sie
also etwas brauchen und sich nicht in
worten ausdrücken können nutzen sie die
nonverbale kommunikation
den menschen würde gern sie monate
arbeitet vor ort wie damals als sie in
kambodscha ankam und mit pierre eine
humanitäre organisation gründete um
frauen und kindern zuflucht zu geben
hager das heißt die frau die fleet und
sich fürchtet
[Musik]
der leiter dieser schule für behinderte
kinder war einer der ersten mitarbeiter
[Musik]
landeka packung in kambodscha und
behinderte menschen haben in kambodscha
keinen platz in der gesellschaft
behinderte menschen bleiben zu hause und
wenn ihre eltern arbeiten gehen müssen
werden sie in ein zimmer gesperrt ans
bett gefesselt sie bleiben zu hause und
tun nichts denn die kambodschaner haben
ein bisschen angst vor behinderten und
denken wenn ich mich die nähere oder ich
berühre oder durch ansehe kannst du mich
krank machen
sie sehen also sarin hat diese schule zu
einer normalen schule gemacht
die schulen die größeren klassen und er
hat seine klasse hier
die kinder draußen zusammen
er arbeitet nicht nur mit den kindern
sondern auch mit den eltern und der
gemeinde um das stigma zu beseitigen
denn diese kinder haben das recht eine
schule zu besuchen das recht in dieser
gesellschaft zu leben
und das recht gesehen zu werden
er kam nach häger als wir anfingen aber
er hatte bereits diesen mut er hat
selbst gesagt ich möchte in diesem land
etwas verändern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
von den zeiten als ich hier anfing sagt
wir okay wir können wir dir helfen ohne
dass wir kamen und das projekt übernahm
sondern in dem besagten okay wir helfen
dir denn du wirst derjenige sein der es
weiter führt du wirst derjenige sein der
sein ganzes leben hier sein wird
[Musik]
sie haben gelitten und doch ich habe
gelitten ich verstehe was sie erlitten
haben und ich möchte ihnen helfen ich
mag diese projekte bei denen ich
jemandem helfen kann der gelitten hat
jemandem der schwierige zeiten
durchgemacht hat um ihn zu unterstützen
bei seinem nächsten schritt dann von
dort kann er weitermachen
mein schwerpunkt legt jetzt hier in
kambodscha ab so viele andere dinge sind
nicht mehr wichtig wissen sehen sie sind
nicht mehr wichtig
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist eine art schicksal das
wir versuchen noch mehr zu tun wir
gerade war um ihn nicht mehr bei uns ist
eines tages wachte ich auf und dachte
wenn ich die situation ändern und
schulen krankenhäuser infrastrukturen
und arbeitsplätze einrichten könnte es
weniger auf
weniger jungen und mädchen missbraucht
und verkauft oder zu internationalen und
lokalen prostitution gezwungen haben
aus diesem grund habe ich shift 360
gegründet
[Musik]
ich habe hart gearbeitet um unternehmen
zu gründen wo sich plötzlich zum
geschäftsmann dann kam das
weltwirtschaftsforum in sagte sie sind
nicht nur in der gesellschaft und nicht
nur in der wirtschaft tätig sie sind an
sozialer unternehmer
es ist also eine diplomatische rolle
geworden weil ich einem anderen land
diener alle meine rollen passen also zu
mir und ich fühle mich gut
ich tue was ich tun muss
[Musik]
bevor
es war nicht
nehmen
die idee ein unternehmen zu gründen das
mit der gastronomie zu tun hat weil hier
immer noch arbeitsplätze geschaffen
werden hier arbeiten 147 menschen die
sehr arm sind viele sind arbeitslos
studenten die arbeit brauchen damit sie
sich ein studium leisten können
[Musik]
wir können studenten aus dieser akademie
in die lehre schicken
diejenigen die hier arbeiten können in
die akademie gehen um ihre fähigkeiten
zu verbessern
[Musik]
also habe ich mir in den kopf gesetzt
nach möglichkeiten zu suchen wie wir
menschen die an der spitze der regierung
entscheidungen treffen und menschen die
an der spitze großer unternehmen
entscheidungen treffen im sinne des
gemeinwohls beeinflussen können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kambodscha braucht infrastrukturen die
verbindung mit dem rest der welt ist
entscheidend wir brauchen ausgebildete
geschulte arbeitskräfte um für
investoren attraktiv zu sein in diesem
sinne hat catania eine schlüsselrolle
gespielt als sozialer unternehmer ist er
der mann in diesem bereich erkennt das
weltwirtschaftsforum sehr gut waren
mehrmals zusammen in davos und konnten
die organisatoren davon überzeugen dass
kambodscha der richtige ort ist um das
weltwirtschaftsforum der asian staaten
auszurichten
[Musik]
dieser enge beziehung zu den
staatsoberhäuptern wuchs bis zu dem
punkt dass wir nach der hausse und zum
weltwirtschaftsforum in jakarta fuhren
und von dort aus eine reihe von treffen
mit der kambodschanischen regierung
organisierten eine lobby zu haben wurde
eine arbeits kommission vom
premierminister gegründet wie einen teil
dieser taskforce bildet
er hat fähigkeiten die ich nicht habe
und er macht gerne dinge die ich nicht
so gerne mache wie zum beispiel an
sitzungen teilnehmen und solche dinge
damit ich die arbeit machen kann die ich
mache bringe ich die diskussionen und
dinge die ich gesehen habe mit nach
hause dann erzählt er mir was in einem
anderen teil kambodschas passiert und
auch ich kann hoffen dass sich die dinge
ändern können
große brüssel
[Musik]
wir brauchen immer eine menge
unterstützung in dieser arbeit zu machen
das bedeutet also dass sich neue
möglichkeiten finden muss um dafür zu
werben und investitionen zu bekommen
[Musik]
wie geht es dir gut danke so christa
bergmann bisschen angekommen gestern
abend in zürich willkommen in unserer
schule
dieses restaurant ist ganz neu bestimmt
du hast mir davon erzählt
[Musik]
diese studenten sind im zweiten semester
sie sind potenzielle kandidaten für
einen austausch mit der akademie
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir weitermachen oder bis
der
nächste schritt ist ein schüler von
unserer schule nach kambodscha zu
schicken damit er ein praktikum in der
gastronomie machen kann
restauration
die beste werbung für die schule sind
die schüler
sind sie am ende des kurses einen guten
job machen bedeutet das dass sie eine
gute schule besucht haben
die schüler müssen einen guten job
machen das ist die beste werbung die man
bekommen kann
da oben ist eine büroeinrichtung
also ist da ein container oder wieviel
22 container was soll ich damit machen
soll ich möbelhändler werden nein aber
du kannst sie für die künftigen büros
verwenden
er klopft unermüdlich an dutzende von
türen bevor er partner findet die
dieselbe leidenschaft haben wie er um
den erfolg der kochschule zu garantieren
reicht es nicht aus schweizer qualität
zu exportieren man muss auch an sie
glauben langfristig
es gibt etwa 50 stühle
sind großartig
das wäre jetzt zb eine vitrine in die
man mineralwasser und getränke zum
verkauf stellen könnte
ich denke das wäre ideal für das café am
eingang
das ist aus dem stapel kühlschränke
geworden die du bekommen hast
[Musik]
die schau mal da drüben kambodschanische
puls
da kannst du ein bad nehmen
wir haben verbindungen zur schweiz über
meine frau auch geschäftliche wie zur
luzerner schüler dann habe ich einen
deutsch-schweizerischen stiftungsrat mit
einem anderen tessin auf meine
verbindung zu den schwarzer kirchen
nicht vergessen
es ist 11 uhr
ab 11 uhr heißt es immer campari
in kambodscha in der schweiz
wir haben überlebt und leben immer noch
von der großzügigkeit der menschen auf
der ganzen welt und im kanton tessin
türen geschlossen hat
[Musik]
simonetta stammt aus wallern ich bin
einmal kantone geboren der bellinzona
aufgewachsen also haben wir natürlich
wurzeln erinnerungen und
kindheitserinnerungen die wir immer
haben bleiben
[Musik]
viele tessiner sind in den späten 80er
und frühen 90er jahren weg gegangen
menschen aus der kantone sind in die
ganze welt gegangen und es gibt viele in
kalifornien in südamerika
das zeigt dass die tessiner hartnäckig
sind dass sie nie aufgeben dass sie
hervorragende botschafter in übersee
sind
und das ist wichtig um sich daran zu
erinnern wer wir sind
[Musik]
gäste keine eindringlinge pia und
simonetta verließen die komfortable
schweiz mit offenen gedanken und herzen
aber sie konnten sich nicht vorstellen
was das betreten des gebiets der roten
khmer bedeuten würde
[Musik]
wenn es besser premier im ersten jahr
kam ich oft um leute zu begleiten die
geld für haga spenden wollen
in den letzten sieben acht jahren breit
nicht mehr hier zu schwer
wie spiegelt sich viel von dem tiefen
leid wieder dass die kambodschaner von
75 bis 79 unter pol pot erfahren haben
es ist also ein bisschen besuchen
17.000 menschen waren hier inhaftiert
fast alle endeten auf den
schlachtfeldern
die roten khmer töteten über zwei
millionen kambodschaner ein drittel der
bevölkerung im namen der extremsten form
des maoismus pierre und simonetta kommen
in ein gebrochenes land
[Musik]
die bevölkerung ist immer noch
traumatisiert
denn viele die die zeit von port
überlebt haben wären immer noch bester
sensor in diesem sinne setzt sich das
vermächtnis der gewalt vor
[Musik]
was ist der wahre grund dafür dass sich
die menschen immer noch fragen warum ist
die roten khmer gegeben hat ich glaube
nicht dass sie bisher eine antwort
bekommen haben und ich glaube es wird
sehr schwierig sein eine zu bekommen
das war die erste zuflucht
sind hier eine schule und ein hotel ja
natürlich haben sie es abgerissen
diese beiden mädchen waren vier und
sechs jahre alt als sie aus einem
bordell befreit wurden dann haben wir
sie in unser pflege familien programm
aufgenommen
sie hier hat geheiratet bei ihr bin ich
mir nicht sicher
man konnte sich an die gesichter den
namen alles von den ersten leuten und
der ersten gruppe erinnern dann verlor
man diese dimension als die organisation
zu groß wurde
das ist unsere familie alle unsere
kollegen mit denen wir angefangen haben
und hat zu mittag gegessen und dann
entschieden welches programm man statt
was man macht es gab keine organisation
wenn er kam aus den flüchtlingslagern
und ich suchte einen leiter für das
willkommens zentrum ein manager der das
zentrum mit den müttern mit kindern für
mich leiten konnte ich fragte ihn nach
seiner führungserfahrung er erzählte mir
dass er im dschungel der anführer des
widerstands mit 1000 soldaten
er bestand also dem führungs testwahl
1000 soldaten geführt hatte ich stellte
ihn sofort als leiter 1
so wurde er vom soldaten zum beschützer
von müttern und kindern
[Musik]
das erste mal dass ich verhaftet wurde
war als die roten khmer versuchten meine
familie umzusiedeln ich lief weg um mich
den vietnamesischen truppen
anzuschließen die gegen die roten khmer
kämpften
ich wurde 1980 und 81 an verschiedenen
orten verhaftet die wechsel
[Musik]
als ich verhört wurde hörte ich wie
einer der soldaten dem anderen zu
flüsterte er solle mich nach draußen
bringen und heimlich töten ohne jemandem
etwas zu sagen
ich begann zu beten und sagte gott ich
weiß nicht wer du bist aber wenn du
mächtig bist bitte ich nicht mehr zu
helfen aus diesem gefängnis zu entkommen
als ich draußen war bat ich darum auf
die toilette gehen zu dürfen bewegte
mich auf den zaun zu und begann so
schnell ich konnte durch die bambus
bäume zu laufen da gibt probleme
20 meter vor dem strand fertig den
wärter schreien der gefangenen ist
geflohen er ist geflohen
und begannen die luft zu schießen
[Musik]
zu diesem zeitpunkt sagten die leute
jeden tag dass der krieg früher oder
später in der stadt ausbrechen würde
überall bürgerkrieg man konnte es nicht
glauben bis 35 kilometer entfernt war
aber als er in der stadt ausbrach wurde
dir nicht gesagt wir kämpfen von morgens
bis 10 oder gehe einkaufen werden ab 17
uhr sind die straßen gesperrt werde
kämpfen müssen und weiß einfach nicht
was passiert und der große frage ist wie
lange wird es dauern
[Musik]
wenn die soldaten kommen werden sie dann
leiden oder gehen das ist eine sehr
schwierige frage nicht wahr als wir
sagten dass wir bleiben und nicht gehen
würden konnten wir sehen die erleichtert
sie waren dass wir sie nicht im stich
lassen
[Musik]
morgen ist der vierte jahrestag von rom
ist tot und wir werden in ihrem namen
einen fonds für die kochakademie
einrichten
wir sammeln gelder für studienbeihilfen
für diejenigen die sich die gebühren
nicht leisten können und wir tun es
nomis gedenken
wir können mit dem was wir getan haben
weitermachen zuerst haben wir mütter und
kinder aufgenommen und jetzt nehmen wir
junge menschen auf die eine praktische
ausbildung brauchen die sie wirklich
brauchen ich denke die beste art nomi zu
ehren ist ihnen die chance zu geben
träume zu haben und darauf aufzubauen
sowie naomis konnte
um eine bessere welt zu schaffen
[Musik]
wir haben bereits ein mädchen ausgewählt
das in häger lebte wir können eine
patenschaft für sie übernehmen und den
kurs betreuen
ich war ungefähr elf als ich hier in
hadamar ii
spielte genau wie diese kinder ein
klassenzimmer war im oberen stockwerk
[Musik]
es war ein bisschen anders als ich hier
war diese tische waren möchte in der
kantine
musst du jetzt auf die akademie
mastro drei jahre oder
22 jahre
[Musik]
ich war sprachlos hat sich an der
kochakademie angenommen wurde mir wurde
klar dass dies der beginn eines völlig
neuen lebens war
mein traum ist es chefköchen zu werden
und zu reisen
ich würde gerne in die schweiz ziehen
[Musik]
es gibt immer noch ein tiefes trauma in
diesem land das viel arbeit erfordert
[Musik]
er hat diese organisation mit viel
herzblut gegründet aber irgendwann
merkte er dass sie zu groß geworden war
und er bat um hilfe um neue werkzeuge
und erfahrung um sie weiter zu führen
die jungs bakijews anhänger konzentriert
sich immer noch auf dieselben werte und
themen dpa eingeführt hat wir
unterstützen schwer missbrauchte frauen
und kinder jetzt konzentrieren wir uns
vor allem auf die posttraumatische
genesung
im laufe der jahre haben wir über 15.000
frauen und kindern geholfen allein im
letzten jahr waren es etwa 1000 menschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich lebe bei meiner tante die fünf
kinder hat vier davon sind schon
verheiratet sie kümmert sich um mich und
meinen bruder als ob wir ihre eigenen
kinder werden
meine tante ist zu hause sie hat kein
einkommen wir sind alle auf das gehalt
von zwei ihrer söhne run gewesen es
reicht nicht zum leben als ich noch
gearbeitet habe konnte ich die familie
unterstützen aber jetzt wo ich studiere
kann ich nichts mehr dazu beitragen
[Musik]
meine mutter starb als ich zehn jahre
alt war und
mein vater starb ein jahr später
[Musik]
wir lebten zunächst bei meiner tante
dann sei ein freund der in haager
arbeitete die ärmlichen verhältnisse in
denen wir lebten und brachte uns ins
zentrum um zu studieren
[Musik]
das leben war immer sehr hart für mich
aber auch wenn es schwer war ohne meine
eltern zu leben
habe ich meine tante die mich immer
ermutigt ich tue mein bestes um
schwierigkeiten zu überwinden
ich werde eine bessere zukunft haben und
zurückgehen um einen verwandten zu
helfen damit sie nicht dasselbe leben
wie ich haben müssen
ich wäre heute nicht hier wenn meine
tante nicht gewesen wäre
mach den behälter nicht zu voll sonst
wird es zu schwerin auszupressen
wir drücken
und 4 führen
[Musik]
er hat die kartoffeln gekocht
wenn die kartoffel nicht mit wasser
bedeckt sind werden sie nicht gar
[Musik]
glück gehabt
hallo
die die chefs kartoffeln sind fertig
also fangen wir jetzt mit der süß saure
suppe an
[Musik]
trend das talent ist an die 30 schüler
sind in drei gruppen aufgeteilt die hier
kochen
was in die die für die kalten gerichte
zuständig sind
muss kochen wir heute
[Musik]
wissen sie woher kommt
was denkst du
es braucht mehr pfeffer mehr pfeffer gut
kürze
das ist ungarischer eintopf
ich habe schon immer gerne gemacht aber
ich habe es nie lernen können ich bin so
froh dass senior kirmes ausgewählt hat
hier zu lernen
[Musik]
am anfang war es schwierig es gab oft
keinen strom weil wir auf einen
generator angewiesen waren der manchmal
nicht funktionierte vor allem nachts
und so hatten wir viele probleme und
sorgen mit der lagerung der waren
man muss sich an die situation anpassen
und wir tun es auch weil die schüler
hoch motiviert sind die studenten es
gibt verständigungsprobleme es gibt
sprachbarrieren aber wenn wir uns nicht
mit der sprache verständigen können tun
wir es mit gesten
[Musik]
hallo was ich will
wir haben die tour beendet gut gemacht
sehr beeindruckend wirklich nicht leicht
sich schlecht für den anfang
[Musik]
wie viel kostet ein kilo
ein kilo 18 dollar gibt es auch größere
die hier sind größer sind die so gut wie
die anderen es sind die gleichen nur die
größe ist anders haben sie etwas größere
nein leider es gibt keine größere es ist
sehr schwer sie zu finden
[Gelächter]
ich nehme 45
im 10 davon
[Musik]
wir machen prosecco risotto mit krabben
angelina jolie risotto für den
schwedischen botschafter es ist das
erste mal also wollen wir sie verwöhnen
[Musik]
sie hatten vertrauen in das menü und
jetzt können sie genau sehen was wir
gemacht haben und sie sind mit dem
ergebnis zufrieden
[Musik]
ins netz
hier arbeitet man mit leuten aus dem
wallis zusammen so macht man das
[Musik]
ich sage wir machen risotto ein
italienisches gericht der rest kommt aus
italien
ich möchte es lernen können sie es mir
beibringen
ich möchte genug geld sparen um mein
eigenes restaurant zu eröffnen
ich bin sehr glücklich hier bei ihnen zu
sein meine eltern sind nicht mehr hier
und sie sind wie ein vater für mich
ja
[Musik]
sorry von meyer ab 6
die eröffnung der hochschule fällt mit
der eröffnung des weltwirtschaftsforums
in phnom penh zu sammeln es ist ein
meilenstein für die region auf den chor
seit jahren hinarbeitet trotz aller
unklarheiten und kritik
investoren und delegierte können sehen
dass kambodscha sich verändert dass es
sich weiterentwickelt genau wie die
arbeit von khatami
[Musik]
ich habe zu simonetta gesagt wenn du
krank bist bleibst du im bett aber ich
sagte heute ist die können nicht zuhause
bleiben ich
habe acht jahre gearbeitet um dieses
ergebnis mit dem weltwirtschaftsforum zu
erreichen das bmf ist wie ein großes
buffet dass initiativen in dieses land
bringt die auch nach dem forum
weitergehen sowohl der privatsektor als
auch die regierung können den
fortschritt kambodschas in der nahen
zukunft verändern
[Musik]
eine rolle besteht darin mit dem
premierminister und den ministern
schritt zu halten andere persönlichen
interessen in der berufsausbildung und
der bildung auf regionaler ebene letzten
endes geht es darum die armut zu
verringern es gibt immer sehr viele arme
menschen es gibt immer
menschenrechtsfragen wir sind mit diesen
problemen konfrontiert also wie können
wir sie lösen
das wmf ist großartig darin die
regierung mit dem privaten sektor und
der zivilgesellschaft zusammen zu
bringen um zu sehen wie sie gelöst
werden können
ich möchte prozent den premierminister
von kambodscha offiziell willkommen
heißen
wir haben die ehre gastgeber des
weltwirtschaftsforums zu sein das sich
mit jungen menschen technologie und
wachstum beschäftigt
dieses großereignis ermutigt die
südostasiatischen länder
zusammenzuarbeiten
zusammenarbeit ist entscheidend für die
entwicklung
die arbeit mit dem mächtigen und
umstrittenen man in kambodscha ist die
größte herausforderung
die redner und die hilfsmittel ändern
sich aber das ziel und die motivation
von khatami bleiben die gleichen
ich habe eine botschaft an die
journalisten von free agent cambodia
daily die mich ständig kritisieren
gerichtet korrekt
ich sage nicht dass ihr mich nicht
kritisieren sollte aber ich möchte euch
daran erinnern dass ihr euch nicht von
ausländern beeinflussen lassen solltet
ihr es ständig zu kritisieren und sich
gegenseitig mit schlamm zu bewerfen
bringt nichts wer am ende des tages
müssen wir immer wieder darauf
zurückkommen dass wir eine plattform für
den dialog brauchen im moment sind diese
leute an der macht und sie sind
diejenigen die die möglichkeit haben zu
entscheiden ich glaube dass es extrem
wichtig ist auf die entscheidungsträger
einzuwirken
[Musik]
ich bin guter dinge es gibt eine
rekordzahl von teilnehmern 700 so viele
hatte es in der asian region schon lange
nicht mehr gegeben
geografisch liegt kambodscha nicht in
einer schlüsselposition aber es ist
ungeheuer interessant
hier ist ein faszinierender
sozialunternehmer
es ist gut diese menschen zu sehen die
für ihr eigenes land arbeiten und von
jemandem wie er unterstützt werden der
das nötige know how hat
diese kombination ist das was wirklich
zählt
[Musik]
man muss weiter träumen wenn man eine
neue welt sehen will neue realität in
der sich die menschen wohlfühlen und
ihre eigene situation verbessern kann
ich bin simonetta und das ist pia und
wir versuchen dass ihr zu machen manche
dinge laufen gut andere nicht aber wir
machen weiter und finden immer wieder
kraft
ich bleibe immer positiv die hindernisse
sind dazu da uns etwas zu leeren
geduld zu lernen
auch wenn man dabei ein paar haare
verliert
[Musik]